Aria Marie Montgomery
will you marry me Pretty Little Liars
just surprised us with a swim worthy
Ezria proposal and only et has the
exclusive images of the ring plus
behind-the-scenes secrets from PLL
showrunner Marlene King oh like put
father this out sort of the one with her
started this sit here and we just
because they work the first sort of
couple we thought they should be the
first to get engaged Lucy and have such
great chemistry and I think there's just
so much fun to watch and as they've
grown up on this show and their
characters have grown up it's sort of
one of those relationships that it's
undeniable I would say as for that
stunning sparkler Marlene dish that they
sorted through dozens of rings before
finding the perfect fit what actually
was something that we spent a lot of
time on because we wanted it to be a
ring that we really felt like Ezra Fitz
would pick out for Aria Montgomery just
something that felt unique to her
something that wasn't you know
necessarily a ring just anybody would
would wear it felt special and like
something Aria would really appreciate
and if you're dying over that pretty
little cliffhanger fans won't have to
wait long for arias answer don't get er
his answer for sure in the next episode
you gotta wait one more episode for the
answer
you